this subject is personal for me and it's
thrifty week here and you're gonna walk
us through not only making the juicy
lucy which is making me drool but you're
gonna give us some thrifty tips yes
exactly okay so juicy lucy as we said
before it's a it's a stuffed burger so
the fir the first thing i'm going to do
is i'm going to make something called
pimento cheese which if you're from the
south you grew up eating this
it's it's basically a couple of
different cheeses like i'm using some
american and some white cheddar uh some
some some diced red peppers a little bit
of cayenne etc and a little bit of
mayonnaise smell the acid too yeah and
and this is this is really used as a dip
um you know with crackers and tortilla
chips and stuff like that no it's not
queso it's called pimento cheese and so
we take a little bit of the pimento
cheese just a tiny bit
we put it in the middle of the burger
and then we take the burger
the other side of the burger and we just
enclose it so basically
you're hiding the pimento cheese inside
the burger
and then drew you want hey bobby why
does yours look nice and mine's already
messy because because you're mad you
know you're making a very indulgent
burger there's a little too much cheese
in there but don't worry about it we'll
get it done i don't know if anybody
knows this without me seal it i'm
you know i'm i'm messy
and i i do go overboard okay and then
what you want to do is you want to make
it look like
it's just a burger and you're hiding the
pimento cheese mine looks weird bobby
compared to yours
mine does look weird
um all right i'm gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna fix this but what is
the money saving tip okay here so money
saving tip here would be a couple things
first of all you can see i already have
pimento cheese left over don't get rid
of it obviously save it for the next day
or two and you can you can put it out as
a as a dip as i said with crackers or
chips and then also
do not buy
um
already formed burgers in the store
you're paying for labor for no reason
buy it in bulk yeah i use 80 20 which is
80 beef 20 fat so you want you like
chuck you just buy some chuck in in bulk
and then make your own burgers this way
you're making the size that you want
them to be anyway and you're not paying
for the extra labor put a little oil in
there thank you canola oil
and then what i what i do is i put a
little salt
and pepper on both sides
you have to put salt and pepper on your
burgers it helps create a crust also
brings out all the flavor from the from
the meat itself so you can see my pan is
nice and smoky as yours okay do you
recommend a skillet
i love that i love these cast iron pans
they really hold the heat they last
forever you can pass them down for
generations well we're gonna let these
burgers fry up break for a quick
commercial and when we come back crust
is gonna be is gonna be happening
welcome back we're here with chef author
and restaurant tour and all around
fantastic human being bobby flay
by the way
i cannot wait to get to your new
restaurant amalfi in las vegas caesars
palace in vegas yeah we just opened
about four months ago i've been obsessed
with italy for decades and i finally
opened an italian
restaurant i mean so it's obviously it's
a lot of fish just from the amalfi coast
bobby and giada
touring through italy
got me through the pandemic and now
you've opened an italian restaurant i'm
there for that today though however
we're making juicy lucy pimento
cheeseburgers from his new book beat
bobby flay all right
and
whoever thought let's make beat bobby
play into a cookbook drink their coffee
that morning all right so what is the
next step now that we've got our crust
on okay so now we're gonna put this on
top of our burger on top of our um bun
our bun thank you very much it ain't no
fun
what i do is i kind of take out the
middle of the bun and then toast it so
you have a good ratio of bun to to the
burger so you could taste more of the
burger so we're going to make a special
sauce here with some ketchup some
mayonnaise and some smoked chilies
smoked
jalapenos i'm just going to put a little
bit of that sauce right on top
and then we have we need we need some
crunch on this as well so i made a um a
pickled relish with some green chilies
and pickles and some some
some pickled onions want me to do this
for you yes please all right
let me ask you a question how do you
feel about bacon
i mean it's candy yeah okay
so so let's let's put it let's put a
slice or two of bacon on there
oh yeah this is insanity right here
thank goodness for minneapolis
since
the juicy lucy was invented in
minneapolis and i'm really a homework
girl and i'm actually furious that i
don't know the history myself but
we are in minneapolis our show is on
w-u-c-w
the cw twin cities and we have a
real-life minnesotan here in our
audience who wants to try it with us
wow
i feel so honored
thank you for joining us in this juicy
lucy heaven you don't know like where
who and when the juicy lucy was invented
we know it was invented there but
there's a couple of places that that
claim ownership to inventing it the
place that i went when i was young and
growing up in minneapolis is called
matt's bar uh but there are other places
that claim ownership um i have been
eating juicy lucy for probably 15 years
now and i actually make my own but i've
never made it with pimento okay so i'm
poor bobby play excited to try it
well
um i have to say i love this concept you
know like breakfast in bed it's
breakfast and audience
i like it it's really good
breakfast anywhere
[Applause]
that's so good i think the relish
really makes a snap is what i would call
conversion yeah it snaps hard
and i love my burgers uh you know
deconstructed after i take a bite
because it feels so good you can be a
judge on beet body flavor i like i like
it
i'll give you my number after the show
when you have a bobby play burger
there's there's just only one thing to
do and that is just embrace the moment
and also like um you want a soft bun so
it becomes part of the burger itself
you're still eating i like it you're not
even on camera anyway that's cool that's
cool
right
a lot of people like like
a really thick potato bun i'm not a fan
no i want like really soft by the way i
forgot the most important question also
other than asking about sophie your
beautiful daughter who you do a podcast
with you guys have such an extraordinary
oh thank you so much father daryl
released so much fun it's called always
hungry uh on
because we're always hungry i love it
but also how's nacho oh nacho
everybody wants to know about nacho
nacho's doing great um you know you were
so nice to
help us yeah
do you have a picture of my cat peach
because i'm also kind of peach and nacho
are happy
look at her
i'm just saying i think there's a dating
situation here well actually your team
was nice enough to invite nacho today
but he's very busy packing boxes to his
new
made by
nacho cat food so
we couldn't get him out of the warehouse
this morning well tell nacho that if he
sees peach on a dating app swipe right
now
i think it's left isn't it i thought
swiping left was getting rid of i have
no idea which one is it
right is good
okay
so if he sees pete's right swipe right
okay wow apparently you're really
polished
okay thank you kareem so much for being
such an amazing
person to do this with
and thank you minneapolis
we love you for so many reasons but this
has got to go right to the top of the
list
and the most amazing genius concept for
a cookbook bobby play comes out tomorrow
be sure to pick up a
copy with me right now
[Music]